[Music]
Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
And thank you Pamela and Robert for
being able to give us this opportunity
to speak. It's inspiring to me because
it feels very American to be able to
speak like this. and that my my children
are coming of an age where they're
wondering what where mommy's going to,
you know, where I'm going and um what
mommy is talking about all the time. So,
it is important that I tell them in a in
a a way children will understand and um
my daughter particularly is starting to
understand this controversy and she
knows what happened to her uncle that
day.
So, I was going to um CPAC last weekend
uh down in Washington and my daughter
said, "Mommy, you know, isn't that a bit
dangerous to be talking about stuff like
that? Maybe the the bad guys are
watching." So, I said to her, "I'm sure
they are, Judy." I said, "I cuz I'm not
going to lie to her, but I said, I'm a
very small fish." And I mentioned um
there's other people much bigger than me
who are fighting this and talking about
this and she said, "Oh yeah, like that
Pamela lady."
But it is so American and it is so
important that we speak out like this.
We cannot allow people like President
Obama, Mayor Bloomberg to speak for us.
And it is so important
on on on 911, you know, I I said one
time about Sean that it it he would have
been proud to have taken the fall that
day. You know, I heard that, you know,
some gave all all gave some. He did take
that fall, but I know he would have been
proud. He was uh a US Marine Corps
reservist. He was on the fire department
eight months. He had been an EMT in the
city. He was so proud of being American.
We We're the children of Irish
immigrants. My mom is sitting here and I
did a little interview about the mosque
today, this evening, just before we came
down and she was with my children for
the full two hours and she didn't even
get a chance to change her clothes. And
I know she's a bit shy to stand up here,
but this is my mom.
[Applause]
the she who made my brother patriotic.
She's from Ireland, but she loves this
country. She made this country her own
and she instilled and Sean and myself
such a respect and love for this country
that made him sign on the USMC dotted
line. So I think that we pe we the
people have to take control and it is
inspiring. The tea part is inspiring.
This is inspiring and we have to fight
the ground zero mosque and we have to
say no not here
[Applause]
and you're all inspiring. Thank you.
[Music]